you
in 2001 dr. Tim hunt was awarded the
nobel prize in physiology or medicine
for the discovery of key regulators of
the cell cycle as part of the inaugural
astrazeneca Nobel medicine initiative
event at the University of Manchester
and neighboring astrazeneca research
center alderley Park dr. hunt gave a
series of talks to students and research
scientists the astrazeneca Nobel
medicine initiative offers the
opportunity for scientists and the
general public to meet Nobel laureates
and hear about their unique discoveries
this was actually a reviewers comment on
the Nobel prize-winning paper and it
raises an interesting so wild
speculation based on faulty logic is not
the kind of thing you want your peers to
say about your work but they were wrong
and I was right so it made it ocean dr.
hunt took part in two days of talks and
open discussions in early december two
thousand and ten most of my great ideas
have not come out of my head from
bumping into somebody in the tearoom the
educational initiative is jointly driven
by astrazeneca and Nobel media it's
fantastic to be able to show our young
scientists that a person of Tim's
caliber really would like to come here
and share his passion for science
fantastic wonderful speaker he's a very
entertaining presence is utterly
charming when you see the high moments
of energy in the room and everybody's
engaged laughing and that's when we
connect together in this part
come I thought was amazing it's really
inspiring it's always really wonderful
to hear from people who've been doing
this for a lifetime's worth and what he
talked about in a very engaging life it
was the the maintenance of curiosity
throughout a lifetime of despite
difficulties I like the metaphor also it
wasn't actually a metaphor but the the
burnt down lab then the really good
thing happened which was the lab burned
up and it was a pretty hot fire and it
destroyed absolutely everything he
really described how he used that
opportunity to start all over again it's
read their minds to think of other
things and they got a breakthrough in
their thinking that they would probably
not have had had the fire not happened
it was a brilliant move sharing stories
behind the Nobel prizes and the work
that went on before and afterwards
offers invaluable inspiration for the
next generation of scientists dr. hunt
also got a chance to talk more
informally with Manchester University
students and directly answer any
questions they had what fields of
science do you think in the future will
allow celeb more as thoughts about
scientific creativity or a last of the
brain to flow more I think you know you
just have to sort of take a journey and
you know the journey starts with putting
one foot in front of the other dr. hunts
lecture to research scientists at
alderley park was followed by a frank
discussion about the relationship
between science and the pharmaceutical
industry we had a great round table on
on tim's request we were discussing
openness because that's that's something
that is really important for Tim and
it's important for us as well I actually
suspect that it wouldn't make a blind
bit of difference if you would totally
open and told everybody about everything
you are doing the way forward is being
more open and being more collaborative
the astrazeneca Nobel medicine
initiative is a global cooperation that
aims to increase understanding of the
Nobel Prize and the achievements within
the fields of physiology and medicine
room Polly though I see of the
mobile medicine initiative is inspiring
all generations to continue to do
science but particularly the generation
of tomorrow it's a way to open up and to
broaden our of use and to make the real
important breakthroughs for the patients
you really do need to get people at the
top of their game to kind of like speak
to not just students and staff but the
general public as well it's a vital part
to science outreach it's just inspiring
for everyone concerned it just makes me
keen to get back to the lab us but that
carries us forward on the days when the
experiments aren't working you know
compounds haven't done what we hope they
would do disappointing days knowing that
but you know you need that perseverance
and so that's the inspiration and I
think it was really motivational for
nobody okay doctor thank you very much
for answering my questions today well
thank you for your question to that was
great thank you
you